In just a moment we're gonna take a
look at what's new in Fermion Spin 0.8.
From TLS for DB connections to JavaScript routing
and OCI registry support.
Let's dive in.
The first thing we're gonna take a look
at is the new JavaScript router.
What does this mean?
Well, typically architecting your Spin applications,
you add a single component for every path
in your application.
However, sometimes,
depending on the complexity of your applications,
you may want a single component that handles
one or more paths,
probably even
a collection of sub pass.
And to do that, the Spin Node JS
SDK provides you with the Eti router.
Let's take a look.
So the GS routing project here
was generated
using spin new.
I select an HTTP
TS for a TypeScript example.
I've literally copied and pasted all of this
code from the release blog,
which is available in the description and on
the screen now.
As you can see, we have the ability
to request a new return from the utils
package.
Now at first you may be wondering, hey,
where where is utils coming from? It's not
imported.
Well, don't worry about it. This is provided
as a global and the TypeScript definition fail.
So you can call it with ease.
From here, we can add
using the HTTP method that we want to
capture
new routes.
Here, we're adding a get route of slash,
and here, a get route of slash goodbye.
You can use any HTTP verb,
such as delete,
patch, post, put,
etcetera.
From in there, you're just writing
any standard spin
endpoint.
As you can see, we can risk around
a 200
and use the encoder to drop goodbye into
the buffer.
Whereas here we just say hello Spin is
handling this route.
To connect the dots we export a handle
request function
which just returns router handle request.
Nice and simple.
This gives you a bit more flexibility into
how you architect and compose your Spin components
and to Spin applications.
Next up, TLS support for outbound database connections.
Previously,
you could talk to any cloud style database
that exposed their API over TLS.
It's a free postgres service
built in a serverless fashion.
It's very easy with a very low friction
onboarding experience,
but I couldn't use it because I needed
TLS.
PlanetScale also offer free databases.
CockroachDB
also offer free databases.
We're in a wonderful world where if you
want to store data for free online and
not have to worry about backups,
policy, RBAC, etcetera,
it's there.
However, it was a challenge to use in
Spin.
Now, that's not a problem.
Using the Rust SDK for Spin,
I'm able to define a show.
I create a try from function to allow
me to coerce
a raw result
from the Postgres driver
into a show struct.
We can add a format column function to
make it easier to print the data to
the terminal.
And then we use the Postgres module
just like we could before.
In fact, nothing in this code is any
different from pre 0.8.
So let's see it working.
In my spin.toml,
I have a Neon Tech, an online free
Postgres database available with my username database, and
I'm hiding my password for now.
I can jump over to the terminal and
run spin up.
Now we have an endpoint that's going to
read all of the shows from my Postgres
database,
and we can run local host 3,000
like so.
This speaks to NeonTech, the remote TLS server
based database,
and spits out my shows to the terminal.
Such a small change, but with powerful possibilities.
Lastly, and probably my favorite feature in zero
point a is support for OCI registries.
This is gonna make interrupt
and hybrid applications for web assembly and containers
a whole lot simpler
because they use the same discoverability and distribution
mechanism as container based applications.
Here we have a Spin application
using the Spin file server,
which delivers static assets
like my very simple index.
HTML.
I provided a just file here. One with
an image name
and here I'm using the GitHub container registry
on my own repository to store exploring Spin
watch news 0.8
application.
We can do a push using Spin OCI
push with the image name.
Even cooler than that, we can sign this
because it's a standard OCI artifact. We can
use cosign
in that suite. Lastly, for the demo, I'm
gonna do a push and sign.
Well, let's run just demo like so.
Spin OCI push is now building
the WebAssembly artifact
into an OCI artifact
and pushing it to get hubs container registry.
Next, cosign is going to sign our image
for us and we can just confirm the
prompt.
This will ask me to log in with
my GitHub credentials
like so.
Now, let's clear screen
and run Just Verify.
This runs a cosign verify against the image
that we just signed. We can see the
claims were validated,
existence of the claims were verified in the
transparency log and certificates were verified against the
Visio route.
And we can see this was signed with
my GitHub
credentials.
Awesome.
And that is spin 0.8.
The Fairmount team continued to impress me with
their velocity,
cool features, shiny new things to play with.
So
we'll see you for the next video in
the complete guide to Spin. Till next time.
Have a great day.